[Música]
desde que somos pequeños nos hacen la
típica pregunta que quiere ser de grande
hay niños que quieren ser doctores
bomberos astronautas científicos
etcétera yo siempre tuve la misma
respuesta quiero ser mamá
de niña cargaba con pañales biberones
muñecos con todo lo que carga una mamá
mi sueño finalmente se hizo realidad el
2 de septiembre del 2018
llegó el isa y me convirtió en lo que yo
tanto había deseado
lamentablemente los doctores nos dijeron
que no podría estar mucho tiempo con
nosotros
debido a que tuvimos un embarazo muy
complicado ya la serie lisa pudieron
darse cuenta que padecía una
malformación intestinal
fueron meses muy duros y difíciles
dentro de un hospital
hasta que el 28 de octubre de ese mismo
año elisa se fue
y allí supe lo que a vivir con la mitad
del corazón y aprender a vivir el gran
aprendizaje que ella me dejó
claro que para lograr este aprendizaje
tuve que atravesar por un duro proceso
de duelo que es nuestra adaptación
emocional después de una perdida y como
todos los procesos este lleva a sus
etapas
recuerdo estar en el funeral de liza
rodeada de muchísima gente todos
llegaban me abrazaban a me abrazaban a
mi esposo y al día siguiente
yo no podía recordar quién había estado
ahí
mi mente estaba en otro lugar
y me di cuenta que yo no creí yo no
podía creer lo que estaba sucediendo
me preguntaba por qué a mí me había
tocado pasar por eso
cuando pasan las primeras semanas me doy
cuenta que estoy molesta con todo el
mundo con mi familia conmigo misma con
dios sin motivo y sin aceptar ayuda o
apoyo de nadie más por más que me lo
ofrecían
hola estaba entrada a la recámara ver la
cuna de mi hija la maleta del hospital
la ropa los pañales y me preguntaba
cuándo volvería a usar esas cosas dónde
estaba mi hija y porque yo tenía los
brazos vacíos
después de dos meses que pasaron
mientras yo estaba sentada en un sillón
comiendo sin parar tratando de llenar el
vacío que sentía en el cuerpo pero sobre
todo el que sentía en el corazón con lo
más cercano que tenía la comida
cuando por fin me doy cuenta de lo que
le estoy haciendo a mi cuerpo llegó la
culpa donde pensé que de alguna forma yo
había provocado lo que había sucedido
con elisa pensé que mis malos hábitos o
que algo andaba mal con mi cuerpo y yo
era la culpable de que mi hija se
hubiera muerto
seguía en depresión pensando en qué
podía hacer para cambiar esa situación
para que no me volviera a pasar
decidí someterme a una cirugía
bariátrica pesando 125 kilogramos sin
pensar que este sería el detonante de
grandes cambios en mi vida
mi proceso con la cirugía fue muy
difícil lleno de depresión ansiedad
frustración y claro que con los cambios
físicos también se vinieron cambios
emocionales sentí que estaba perdiendo
todo lo que me hacía ser yo mi identidad
me podía ver en el espejo y no reconocer
a la persona que estaba viendo
metros cosas que antes me interesaban me
gustaban dejaron de importarme empecé a
ver la vida más tranquila y quise
vivirla más despacio
yo no necesité contar mi historia ni una
ni dos ni tres yo conté mi historia mil
veces para poder asimilar la y parecía
que cada que la contaba un pedacito de
mi corazón volví a encenderse
descubrí que sea mi forma de mantener
vive lista
contando lo valiente que fue el amor que
me dio y que no se dejaba vencer
comencé a confiar en mi red de apoyo y
un día platicando con una persona muy
querida me dijo cuando pasas por cosas
así y te hundes está en ti decidir
volver a ser feliz
lo confirmo decidí ser feliz con lo que
aún me quedaba mi esposo mi familia mis
amigos mi trabajo
cuando estamos pasando por un proceso
así todos tenemos distintas formas de
sobrellevarlo
otros contamos nuestra historia mil
veces para poder asimilar la unos lloran
y las y las lágrimas les ahogan las
palabras otros se guardan sus
sentimientos para poder para aparentar
fortaleza
con el tiempo vas a ver lo bueno que te
rodea agradecerán los momentos en los
que te ríes en los que lloras y
entenderás que esos pasos tan duros
tienen una finalidad hacer evolucionar
tu persona
lograrás tener una solución a cada
problema y dejarás de preocuparte por
cosas sin sentidos como maría ya no
quiere ser mi amiga no me seleccionaron
para el equipo odio las matemáticas del
maestro me son mala cara etcétera en
algún punto la vida te va sacudir y de
todo corazón deseo que te sacuda
despacio y que aún así tu aprendizaje
sea muy grande
cuando termine de escribir esta plática
puede darme cuenta que aún sigo en el
proceso porque aún duele
pero es un dolor más llevadero más
quieto y que admiro las decisiones que
tome para llegar hasta donde estoy ahora
gracias a la vida por dejarme sobrevivir
a esto gracias a dios por darme la
fortaleza para avanzar
gracias a mi familia ya mis amigos por
no soltarme
pero sobre todo
gracias también lisa
por llegar a este mundo hasta cubrirlo
todo
a mover cada fría hasta mover cada fibra
y enseñarme que puedo ser resiliente
te invito a no dejarte caer y si esto
sucede busques ese motivo para salir
adelante
que confíes en tu red de apoyo y que
está bien y se vale estar triste
ahora después de dos años y medio con 50
kilogramos menos llevando en mi vientre
mi tercera oportunidad para hacer una
mamá en la tierra puedo decirte que se
puede salir adelante que puedes avanzar
pero sobre todo te puedo decir que todo
lo bonito que yo haga en esta vida
va para ella para mí elisa muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]